so as you serve on the house Foreign
Affairs committee that it is a great day
to have Brittany Greiner coming home to
the United States Victor boot has also
been said a very steep price to pay but
what about what Lucas just mentioned
which was the tradition that you try to
bring people home and the order in which
they were taken
well I think this is a great day to have
Brittany home I'm happy for her and for
her family horrible experience I'm sure
but the real problem here is just the
weakness of this President we got a
marine sitting over there
we traded this Merchant of Death guy who
was going to Target U.S military
personnel and so what is the message
we're sending to the people serving in
our military or who might one day serve
we'll leave the Marine in the jail in
Russia uh we'll we'll free the guy who
was going to Target U.S military
soldiers and and just get you know the
high profile basketball player
um it's it's a terrible message to send
it's so funny that it's legit like a
trade first round pick but he's right
like you know it's funny I hadn't even
thought of the what our military must
feel like so this guy wants to kill us
and we're going to trade him for a
basketball star and leave one of our own
over there why wouldn't we just throw in
the Dude too be like we need both we
need both yeah and and and really win in
a negotiation for once under this
Administration and why if we're going to
have anybody I'm sorry why does why not
why how does the basketball player Trump
the veteran in in priority I just and
and you know what Brittany grinder
pisses me off she she [ __ ] all over this
country but you know I I still don't
want any American over in a Russian
prison I mean why does Russia want that
dude back if he's a terrible person I
don't know enough about him but that's
weird of them to be like give us a
criminal back in exchange for her like
why do they want this dude because don't
they have Law and Order there like they
don't just want people going around
blowing [ __ ] up right but maybe he's not
so bad there so he's just good there but
maybe he is still bad there maybe they
want to either but what do they think
they don't care they don't care that he
was going to kill American troops or
maybe they want to punish him on their
own terms it's just weird it's just
weird to me I'm like what like that's
who you guys are going for it's just
weird I don't know that maybe okay all
right you know you're looking at an
angle that I hadn't looked at but still
why her why her over our veteran and
this extra layer of of grossness that I
really hadn't thought of and now I feel
even worse about this situation let's
see what else they have to say not only
to the despots of the world who now know
that they can get a trade if they just
capture an American but to the military
the United States military who are
saying yeah I can serve this country and
the president will leave me and take the
the basketball player
well we hope uh Paul whalen's health is
better than apparently it was I wonder
what the U.S soldier is there for yeah I
don't know did he have a little weed
cart too I would like to see what if the
if this they say this that is pretty
insane though that I mean she shouldn't
have done it like you I feel like you
should know better not to do that show
with Russia she's an idiot
[ __ ] idiot I don't care but I still
you know it still sucks to go to jail
over like a weed cart that's that is
crazy yeah it was like a vape with a
marijuana Vape or something but you know
what like in Russia's eyes they use that
as a great example like no I'm sure no
one's doing that [ __ ] again sorry for
her in the sense that like you're an
American they hate check reason to hate
you there uh you're black they hate
black people there uh you're lesbian
real hard on the gay community there
they hate them there too so she had all
the and then a drug user so she had like
so many checks against her on Russian
culture this is a woman who you know
hated hated America and wouldn't stand
for the anthem and shout all over us so
I do hope that she learned her lesson
and I know we're gonna have do you think
she'll do that again she'll she'll kneel
for the flag oh I can't wait to hear all
the traumatic in all the interviews and
the traumatic stories and all this and
we're going to hear in the next 24 hours
right now I'm just gonna take time to be
with my family and get used to being
home again and I'll talk to the press as
soon as I'm ready and then she'll have
some big Whopper interview with some
major German documentary or some [ __ ]
about it yeah Barbara Walters type and
they're gonna they're gonna be it's
gonna be a bombshell uh Revelations
about what goes on in Russian prisons
and we're all going to feel sorry for
her like Russia like Russia of all
places you just go to Amsterdam well she
was going for work but don't bring your
weed to Russia you [ __ ] idiot you
know so like I I I've possibly been
there she got what she deserved because
she broke laws she broke their laws and
now a veteran is rotting in a Russian
jail while she's home in her own bed and
spoke in the Wayland at Great length
today that would give his family
um I imagine some mentioned how his
family feels apparently the last time
you talked to that might have been or
two ago when he was in that hospital sir
yeah no doubt he he obviously has some
health issues I mean this guy needs to
come home uh served our country uh he
needs to come home and and he should
have been the guy who came home or at
least get two why is he there that's
what he's saying all right get two for
one Norms dealer a convicted arms dealer
who's again as you guys mentioned
targeting American soldiers to kill them
and we couldn't get our president so
weak he couldn't get you know uh these
two guys for this one uh terrorist
really it's shameful and I guess it's
just under this seems like all just like
Matrix [ __ ] to keep us distracted like
our president couldn't negotiate strong
enough like there's like other people
dealing with a lot of this [ __ ] too you
know what I mean though do I sound wrong
like do I sound crazy for saying that
yeah you do because right now because we
have a president who's at the mercy of
Russia and China and every other
president doesn't even run [ __ ] it's the
face of it yes right the face of a
company is responsible for its employees
and what an employee does I don't every
employee does so when someone in Burger
King spits in your Whopper before
because they didn't like how you ordered
it yeah you know the presidential
company you know ultimately is in an
interview he has to answer for that I
don't know how he didn't just throw in a
couple troops in the deal like how hard
would that have been maybe the dude did
did he do something crazy he don't have
leverage we do not have leverage with
the other superpowers anymore we don't
the second we pulled out of Afghanistan
we showed the whole world that this we
have a weak president who's taken [ __ ]
from anybody that wants to give it to
him so that's what happened here so he
should have been able to negotiate much
more strongly a basketball player
for a guy called The Merchant of death
it's not stupid and this is the heavy
duty [ __ ] this is not just Matrix
[ __ ] don't play light with this I
know but because because there's there's
you know International Trade Warfare all
these things that all play a role in how
much leverage you have with another
Nation so yes Putin's Representatives
and Biden's Representatives sat together
Putin and Biden didn't sit and have this
conversation but their representatives
have the power and the backing of of
their nation and Russia is winning in
negotiations with the United States yeah
I'm not denying that sure because his
admire Administration is hiring based on
things like should have thrown in
whether or not you have a vagina or if
you have a penis and you wear a dress
extra you get extra points in the job in
the job interview process instead of
who's actually qualified leaders you
know Warlords basically for uh Beau
Bergdahl so he was trained by the best I
guess in doing bad deals
well the but they also the other thing
is you know that that is an opinion that
we can maybe set aside for just for a
moment but it was the Obama
Administration that was able to get boot
he was a number one wanted uh person in
the world at the time and this it's not
just Americans he was targeting that
this guy has basically an ocean of blood
on his hands across the board it was the
Biden Administration excuse me the Obama
Administration that helped get bring him
to Justice there was a press release in
2011 saying that boot was convicted of
conspiring to kill U.S Nationals and U.S
officers and employees
um so
on that score wow guilty of conspiracy
to kill US citizens oh this is the dude
this is the dude yes this is a much
heavier for prisoner with
with mysterious convictions and much
more serious potential damage to the
world that we gave away in exchange for
a [ __ ] WNBA player are you kidding me
would you rather I mean no no offense
Brittany like would you rather one
dollar or finals tickets to the WNBA
Courtside would you rather one dollar I
can sell the tickets right no you have
to go no I'm not going back you take one
dollar take the back go buy a scratch
ticket would you take the tickets or the
dollar the dollar yeah I mean I don't
know I have no interest in going to see
a game me neither none I don't think
anyone does like right but the women
should get paid the same as the men even
though they don't sell tickets that [ __ ]
that's just dumb though like I don't
even listen to those people yeah let's
take it Mario opal and we make a deal
with this guy to give away a a convicted
uh murderer uh arms dealer all of that
for just one person we should have got
two if we'd have if this leader was
strong if our president was strong
useless person
do you see where I'm coming from when
this sounds hilarious like not like
obviously it's a serious situation but
it's like we're trading basketball
player for terrorists and in exchange
for a first round it's just like it just
looks crazy to me you know what I mean
okay so maybe maybe there is something
else going on behind the scenes I don't
think this is a I don't yeah they're
always this you're right I don't think
this is a typical smoke screen that they
use to try to distract us because some
of those stories a lot of the stories
I'll say that to you I'll be like this
feels like a distraction and wonder what
else that what what's really going on
here that they're trying to keep our
attention off of this is just yet
another failure in my opinion and if
they were trying to distract us with the
story I don't think this would be it
because this just reeks a failure uh she
is coming home and the healthy she
experience is now over uh on board that
floor and she lands sometime around four
or five o'clock this afternoon maybe
even in Washington DC and her wife said
that she and Brittany will continue to
try to help bring Waylon home as as well
as anybody else that's being held
unjustifiably all right that that's nice
to hear that if she actually what did
they say that they're going to try
they're gonna try to do what they can to
bring Whalen home the other guy that's
left over there so who the family
Brittany greiners her and her her wife
made a statement that said that they
will work to try to bring what are they
gonna do nothing yeah she's gonna get
right back onto her one of her okay
right Putin one to ten I'm in the middle
of a sentence she's gonna get right back
onto her I hate America training and
poor me poor me poor me so she's not
really gonna give a [ __ ] about this
other guy if she's not gonna care she
doesn't care about our veterans she
cared about our veteran she would have
stood for the national anthem yeah I
mean I I feel like you it's it's a weird
one for sure but I feel like you can
like care about it but then also just be
brainwashed into thinking BLM was the
most important thing in the world like I
feel like I could still care about the
veterans but I feel like this is my this
is my duty to stand for it you know what
I mean I will never reconcile caring
about ending racism and kneeling for the
flag or burning the flag or peeing on
the flag or all the things stomping on
the flag and all the things that I saw
those things things should not happen in
unity if you care about this country and
you care about improving it burning its
flag does not show that you care maybe
this Brittany Greiner will come home and
finally say I would love to hear her say
I am sorry I was wrong I appreciate
America in a way I never could have
possibly imagined and I am so grateful
to the American people for the time
money and resources that they put into
getting me back because I can't even
imagine how much [ __ ] money we had to
spend because she couldn't live without
her hot Vape we'll see what she says who
knows maybe she'll go off about racism
and they didn't get her back soon enough
we'll see there's definitely racism in
Russia and they definitely have
anti-lgbtq laws Putin's a psycho he's my
favorite Mega villain but still a psycho
all right so who was I rating who are we
given one to ten potent on what on
cruelty nine let's go maybe eight he
could be worse 8.5 well you got to step
up your game Putin what are you doing
all right thank you guys so much for
watching I'm giving away a hundred
dollars to someone who follows my
Instagram so make sure to do that and
then like and comment on the recent post
to enter thanks for coming by
I want to say what to say hey
[Music]